[Musique]
salut hey mon pote j'ai ce gamin je
te parlais de lui je vais le
mettre au téléphone laisse toi lui parler d'
accord oh oui c'est toi Frank c'est Jimmy
Hoffa
on se retrouve content de te rencontrer aussi  même
si c'est au téléphone notre ami parle
bien je
t'entends merci il n'y a que trois personnes dans le monde
et une de ces
[musique]
et une seule d'entre elles est irlandaise je t'ai entendu
peindre des maisons oui je le fais alors où
vas-tu aller  fonctionne bien vous savez quelle
est la situation en ce moment Frank les grandes
entreprises et le gouvernement qu'ils
essaient de nous tirer vers le bas vous pourriez
démontrer un échec à montrer votre
appréciation Je savais des choses qu'ils ne
savent pas pourquoi pas
vous ne pouvez pas manquer le  grande image tôt ou
tard
tout le monde pourrait entendre comme une date il
ira
tu veux faire partie de ce combat
voudriez-vous faire partie de cette
histoire oui je ferais
tout ce que vous avez besoin de moi je suis disponible
il aime un dur  chien
toi